foreign
just a wonderful woman who I'm not going
to name her I failed to ask if I could
um but I know she watches Dark Horse and
she is finding herself
angry
and in talking Angry that so many among
her circle of oldest friends and some
among her family
are responding to her like she's the
problem
and for
for
not vaccinating her children
for not wearing a mask when she's
outside
for not trusting the public health
officials that we know have been lying
to us now for a long time
and not trusting the next thing that
comes out of their mouths
for this she is being told that she is
wrong and
I began to say how they judge us don't
they and I realized in this this
conversation I had with her no we're all
judging each other now we are all
judging each other we are
we seem to be so many of us increasingly
certain
of our positions and I then I also saw a
piece of theater in Portland
that put this into very sharp relief
uh in which a person who has simply
adopted it was a it was a one-woman show
a person who is simply adopted
all of the narratives from the
mainstream and the public health
apparatus
as
as the truth as the only truth
as the forever truth
has said
I was watching her certainty and thought
well okay how is her certainty how are
the people in our Lives who are angry
with us for making these decisions that
we feel more and more certain were the
right ones how is there certainty
different from our certainty
and one of the things I arrived at was
we didn't start out certain
we started out skeptical and hesitant
and employing the precautionary
principle
with things like
where's this virus from
what might it do
how's it going to proceed
let's use the wisdom that we do have as
for instance evolutionary biologists as
bat biologists as people with a history
of thinking about granting agencies
and figure out what we think might be
true and figure out what the predictions
of those ideas would be and let's see
what happens
and when for instance the code vaccines
were beginning to be rolled out and we
were told they're safe they're 100 safe
there are a lot of us who said
you've just lied to us
not because we didn't not because we
knew that they weren't 100 safe because
we didn't
but because we knew that they couldn't
know no no you got to be careful about
that they could not be 100 safe if they
didn't know whether or not they did harm
they could have been 100 harmless
but the safety comes from knowing that
they do know I maybe this is important
it doesn't strike me as important at the
moment
um that that distinction
um and I think that's going to muddle
the issue here because this is a very
important issue and I I think you're
going to have to let me not go down that
semantic road for the moment and you can
you can do the verification that you
think you need to afterwards
our objections not just us but so many
people
so many people's objections people with
scientific training people without
scientific training people in all lines
of work
at the point
that a new medical treatment is brought
to Market and we are told they're 100
safe what we know for sure is you can't
know that
there hasn't been time
we are uncertain we were at that point
uncertain we in fact figured we assumed
we're going to wait as long as possible
and then we'll get them because we're
gonna
we will get them probably right and then
weeks past and months passed and more
and more evidence
did become public and it became clear
clearer and clearer that actually I'm
not safe
not effective
by contrast the people who
were certain in the other direction
started out that way
they were told by people who were not
telling them the truth these are safe
and effective and they said ah they're
safe and effective and anyone who says
differently is a conspiracy theorist and
anti-factor or whatever
and so
the prediction I want to make
which is maybe maybe prediction isn't
even exactly the right word here but the
prediction I want to make is that even
though I at this point
have a high degree of certainty that for
instance the coveted vaccines are
neither safe nor effective
I did not start out that way
and I think that the of the if you take
the the two camps such as it is over in
coveted vaccine territory
uh the what is wrong with you people why
are you putting us all In Harm's Way
take the damn vaccine crowd
and the absolutely not I'm not going to
do it and what are you doing to your
children crowd
at the moment the people in these crowds
seem to have similar levels of certainty
with opposite valences but the
prediction is that the people over there
are some people over in the I'm not
getting near your damn vaccine crowd who
started out that way and they were also
being non-scientific in their approach
right
but they're
my prediction is that there are more
people over in the I'm not taking that
treatment crowd who started out on
certain and skeptical and hesitant at
using the precautionary principle and
using science and as more and more
evidence came in developed a higher
degree of certainty because that's what
science does for you
and that by contrast the people over
here who
started out certain that they that this
was going to be the thing that ended the
pandemic
have changed in no way in their
certainty even as evidence has arrived
in abundance to the contrary that their
cert their degree of certainty has not
changed and when you see anyone with a
position whose degree of certainty has
not changed you know they are not
thinking logically you know they are not
thinking scientifically and you know
that for all of their talk about nuance
and being following the science and all
that they are wrong whether or not
they're deceiving themselves or just
deceiving you I don't know it doesn't
matter but they are wrong
all right several things to say about
this one I want to point out that there
are two instances in which I know myself
to have visibly changed my position in a
way that you could even go back and
check in in this pandemic in the context
of the pandemic one of them is at the
very start the following thing can be
found on Twitter
you and I as we've talked about before
did not know about the novel coronavirus
until we emerged from finishing the
first draft of our book where we were
deep in the Amazon where we had no
connectivity unaware that there was a
new story Brewing as we emerge to the
first place that your phone connects a
military checkpoint end of January 2020.
yep we emerged to news we were in
Ecuador we emerged news that there was
this novel coronavirus which we started
to wrap our minds around and oddly that
the first case had just arrived in
Ecuador so we're getting information on
our phone in Spanish new case novel
coronavirus from China
Etc
um
as I looked into it story was this was a
bat virus that had jumped to humans I
knew something about the family of bats
in question because I had been a bat
researcher
and I tweeted something that said I
haven't looked very deeply into this
story but so far it seems to check out
right I know these animals I know
something about these viruses
circulating in these animals it looks
right to me and I got back a tweet from
an account that uh I knew only online
and the account said something like yeah
right it's a coincidence that this
happened in you know uh in a city that
had a a level four
um biosafety level for lab studying
these exact viruses
and I looked at that and I thought what
don't I know
what the hell that is a weird
coincidence
that thought what don't I know
anyone who doesn't ask themselves that
question on the regular is also not
trustworthy right thing is so I
retracted my claim that this story made
sense I didn't yet know what made sense
but I knew at that point that there was
something here that I had not factored
into my calculation so whatever I had
said publicly didn't make any sense and
you know it could have been that it was
that the story did check out and that
the existence of the laboratory in Wuhan
was a coincidence
um you know which I guess I would have
figured out over time but the point is I
believe the two tweets are separated
just by accident by exactly an hour
right that the whole thing the
recognition that I had said something
that I now knew was not grounded because
it missed the whole set of facts that
were potentially relevant that's
captured in the space of exactly one
hour in that case and it could have been
an hour a day a week a month a year it
could have been anything it could have
been anything but the point is you went
back and you said ah my level of
certainty was too high and as it turns
out the wrong valence right right and so
anyway this is I mean and you know makes
I remember my emotional state that I
like saying hey I said something
scientifically about something in my own
discipline and now you know an hour
later I've got to take it back do I like
that no but it's far better far better
than sticking with a wrong idea because
it would be embarrassing to admit that
it was wrong you know well there's a
sunk costs fallacy there too right that
you did not succumb to but that most
people do well I've already done the
thing I've already like this is it
something maybe it's not maybe that's
not quite the right fallacy there's a
like I don't there's a good one it's
good money after bad okay that's that's
it so I don't oh this is going to be bad
for this is going to feel really
uncomfortable the longer you wait the
worse it gets guys well you know and I
think
the thing that is important not to have
done right one could do the calculation
and say well okay
I've just learned something I didn't
know it changes my private certainty
about how
sensible the story that I've heard is
but it's possible that the story that I
believe is correct is still going to
turn out to be correct so if I can just
the zoonotic origin yeah if I can just
put off making a correction then it's
possible the problem solves itself right
that's not that is a way to get yourself
in trouble which is why I didn't do that
right the right thing to do is to say
actually as of now I'm aware that even
if the natural origin story turns out to
be right that it has to overcome a
threshold that I didn't even realize
existed because I didn't know that that
lab was there
that's just so beautiful that like that
right there that is an encapsulation of
both what you do
and what all scientists should do and
what everyone should do in communicating
with the world having made a statement
and Having learned that there's more
to the thing that you pronounced upon
with such certainty
be like brats like do that well you'll
also you'll be you'll just be happier
right because the fact is the relief
that you experience for having gotten
yourself back to ground you're
comfortable with right the point is
you're actually taking a risk saying
yeah I've looked at this paper seems to
add up thing emerged from
bats you know in some normal way right
and then it's like oh goodness what what
didn't I know right there's a fact I
didn't have and then the point is that
the point you say publicly uh actually
this fact potentially looks important I
need to know more about it then it's not
haunting you it's not lurking waiting to
LEAP out you know you're not you know
constantly keeping track of how much
danger this thing you said is leaving
you in so anyway just even just from the
point of view of your own sanity it's an
honest accounting it's an honest
accounting that means that in the
present you don't have to worry about
saying too much or something like that
and that's not to say so I mean I think
I a different approach the approach that
I have tended to take is I don't like
and you know until relatively recently
this is 100 like I just don't make
pronouncements out into the world until
I've actually you know I'm really
prepared to do it because I don't want
to have to keep track of all of the
things that I've said that I then would
do have to actually go and and correct
when you know when when I'm wrong and
obviously podcasting changes that
Dynamic quite a lot but I was thinking
specifically of social media like I
actually I
there is just there is such a joy and
like a human potential in sitting in
uncertainty and being like oh this thing
is happening
I don't know what it means I don't know
what the significance is I don't know
where it came from I don't know what
it's going to do
and yet we
in the following two months we're having
these conversations around our dinner
table every day and we're like you know
I think actually these conversations
that we're having are worth sharing and
that was actually what began the live
streams I began to say to you as you
know our boys schools were being shut
down it's like we actually have things
to share and we weren't right about
everything early on at all by any means
right but we were having conversations
by which
we were we were demonstrating how you
might figure out what is true and that's
the thing is it's not like were you
right it's like do you have a process
for becoming right the process for
becoming right involves the uncertainty
it involves saying things that turn out
to be wrong discovering that they are
wrong being honest with yourself and
others about it that's that's the
process and you know science formalizes
a piece of this but nonetheless it's
it's obviously the right thing to do now
if if I think back I remember exactly
where we were during this one hour
uh
wobble between perspectives here and I
remember I think my thought process why
did I weigh in on a story that was so
new right why not just hold off and see
and I believe that my thought process
was
how many bat biologists does the world
know
right not that many right I studied
under actually one who became quite
famous she now tragically died very
early in the field Elizabeth calco who
uh you know you you've probably heard
that XI jang li was called the Batwoman
because she studied bats in China well
no the real bat woman was Elizabeth
calco and she was a force to be reckoned
with but anyway
the point is the world does not know
very many bad biologists I happen to be
a bat biologist with hundreds of
thousands of Twitter followers and I
felt an obligation to say something
precisely because I didn't want
conspiracy uh uh undisciplined
conspiracy thoughts to emerge from this
people who showed up certain on the
other side without any evidence right
right certainty at the beginning of
anything like this is is a tell yeah
you're not thinking carefully are you
trying to sell me something are you just
confused at some level it doesn't matter
you're not thinking carefully right so
what I said was effectively
you know this isn't my story I don't
have a dog in this fight but I do know
the bats right I know that these viruses
circulate amongst them the story I see
written here makes sense to me right and
that basically says look on a first pass
this is a plausible story
wasn't the plausible story it turns out
right and the process of discovery that
led there
um you know does involve a willingness
to be uncertain including in the first
you know hour after you've said what you
thought was a I mean I didn't say
anything you didn't say the story is
true yeah I said I think it checked out
it looks superficially looks right
um
the other place where uh my wrong
initial perspective is absolutely
captured
is masks
of which as you know I was we talked a
lot about masculine we talked a lot
about Mass I was very early on
um using masks and advocating for them I
you made me so grumpy
I did not want to go into stores masked
early on and you're like it's the thing
and I I came around and then we both
came around the other way but and you
know I look I you know I had a model in
my head and I remember I talked about it
I showed it uh on Dark Horse in which
the idea was well how much I can use my
camera to tell me how much light is
blocked by a bandana
and it's a fair amount and
um that to me suggested the likelihood
that particles would be blocked and you
can say well particles are too tiny they
go through the holes apparently they do
but photons are also very tiny what
photons don't do is you know there's no
flow pattern around a fiber right the
photon hits the fiber or it doesn't it
doesn't you know Steer around it whereas
air flowing over probably brings the
particles through the mask which is
probably why they don't work very well
excuse me but the following thing also
occurs to me in hearing uh your
description here
which is that we had this recent you
know you say we're all judging each
other and I think this is this is true I
think I know that when I see people
wearing masks I have a thought that I
can't stop especially when I see them
wearing masks outside right it's like
okay how what what model is running
around in your head you know years into
this that you still think it makes sense
for you to mask yourself Outdoors but
I'm gonna say here's something to you
that you often say to me while I'm
trying to figure out what is going on in
their heads and you say it's not like
that like very often and I I assume that
in some cases it is a model and it's
just a bad model but very often it's not
a model and this is this is to my point
about they arrived at the certainty upon
being told a thing and it doesn't get
updated it's not a model it's not a
complex living thing it's a conclusion
end of story done
right now this is exactly this is
exactly where I'm headed is that you and
I had the following uh
episode in our in our own life a minor
thing but you and I uh had an
appointment with somebody
and I can't remember which one of us had
come down with a slight respiratory
something you know a little cold that
under ordinary pre-coveted circumstances
would not be worth even mentioning it
just would be like oh that's annoying
um
but
we were going to meet with this person
and in light of covid for the first time
this wasn't someone we knew before right
yeah I felt it was necessary to warn her
and to give her the option to cancel the
meeting in case this was covered right
and she suggested quite rightly how
about you wear a mask and I said how
about we don't wear masks and we meet
outside and when we go inside to look at
the samples or whatever it was that we
needed to see that then we will put on a
mask but then two in fact he doesn't
share a mask no we had two entirely
different masks um
but
I remember having the weird thought like
I do not want
the cost
of being seen to wear a mask which
implies either a simplistic and wrong
model of covid or no model at all as you
point out is likely going on with many
of these people and so it was like
actually the fact that I don't wear a
mask I certainly don't wear a mask
Outdoors but in this case I was going to
put on a mask right now that becomes
complex it's actually evidence that
pattern if you saw you know hour after
hour of not wearing a mask and then you
know slight respiratory something and
because I'm the person who might be
spreading whatever it is wearing a mask
makes more sense
um you know that's evidence of a nuanced
model it's not evidence of the absence
of a model but because masks are
something that we now judge each other
for because of the way that they have
been politicized
um
it was it was a tough calculation that
shouldn't have been yeah the right thing
to do was to say look there's very
little harm in it in this case it's not
I'm not committing to wear a mask you
know in general it just it happens
as a courtesy it made sense
[Music]